ce portrait sans doute le plus beau
témoignage de l'amitié qui lie elle est
peintre léon cogniet et achille et namy
chalon les deux camarades remporte le
prix de rome de 1817 l'un comme peintre
d'histoire l'autre comme peintre de
paysages historique le premier dans
l'histoire de l'académie
il quitte paris pour rome en 1817 jusqu
en 1821 où ils vont partager ensemble
quatre années de peinture et de
découverte de l'italie
ce portrait être réalisés dès leur
arrivée à la villa médicis où léon
cogniet va laisser cette image de grands
romantiques qui aujourd'hui encore
imprègne les murs du musée ses cheveux
devant son visage d'ange et son air très
romantique attire toujours les regards
des visiteurs qui découvrent ce table
rester dans le fond d'atelier de léon
cogniet
[Musique]